hi there steve kaufman here today i got
a little bit of a strange video i'm
going to talk about a thing called
cultural appropriation
and a concept which i don't fully
understand and i'm sure people will
help me to understand but
you know i uh i have this and by the way
and the reason i'm doing it because
there was uh something i came across on
twitter
and it says
for those of you into anime i'm sure
you're aware of whatever wee boo problem
some white anime fans love to
appropriate japanese hairstyles musical
tastes and even the japanese language
itself
this blog demonstrates the problems of
non-japanese people learning japanese
spanish is another issue you know so
many white kids are proud to be able to
speak spanish so
this idea that if you are white you
shouldn't learn japanese
somehow
spanish is identified with
latin americans who may be therefore not
white so therefore spanish is not a
white language if there is such a thing
now to be fair i don't know if this
tweet is a parody
if this is really somebody's opinion
but it made me think about the issue
of culture as opposed to
ethnicity and i am a firm believer that
culture is separate from ethnicity it
can be part of and in most cases it is
but culture is out there and anyone can
participate in any culture it's
something that human beings have have
created over time
we can participate in culture that was
created a thousand years ago created by
different people lived in different
countries and that's part of my
motivation for learning languages and by
the way i'm going to
finish this
video by speaking for asian languages
again i haven't prepared a korean might
suffer a bit
just to demonstrate that i don't believe
in this idea that
culture belongs to only this group and
other groups can't uh participate
uh you know i'm not a big fan of this
whole you know identity politics thing
that i
you can choose to identify
however you want but that doesn't give
you the right to prevent
other people from also participating in
that culture
and the history of the world is one of
people appropriating other people's
culture
you know what we
sometimes call you know western culture
european culture is first of all already
a mixture of cultures
where people in france were dominated by
the romans and so they end up speaking a
romance language instead of the
presumably celtic language that they
originally spoke
we have all the people of south america
who either have spanish or portuguese in
small number of cases french as their
native romance language but if in the
case of haitians
they're originally of african origin
uh you know brazilians are part native
part african part portuguese origin and
they come together around a sort of a
sense of being brazilian with all of the
cultural things that the brazilians have
developed which is a mixture of all
these other influences
uh
as i say the western
culture which is
you know to some extent based on
you know
scientific development and exploration
and conquering other people and lots of
bad things that were done
but they relied to the largest stand-on
technology that was developed in china
such as the compass
such as even metallurgy which was very
advanced in china you know two thousand
five hundred years ago
uh
printing presses gunpowder are these are
some of the tools that european
culture call it used
to
dominate other parts of the world not
that the white europeans were the first
people to go out and dominate other
people nor the last because the mongols
and the turks and
you know the the arabs who
brought their religion and language and
basically
took over
areas of of the middle east where they
spoke uh
i don't know aramaic or whatever they
spoke there uh north africa where they
spoke berber
the whole history of the world has been
one of people conquering people cultures
blending mixing that's the nature of the
world and the fact that a particular
group
is perceived as a minority and therefore
at a disadvantage they're not a minority
everywhere
because there is a place where they are
the majority so therefore they may be
suffering
you know prejudice discrimination in
those places where they are a minority
because that tends to happen around the
world not just in western countries but
i have lived in japan and i can tell you
that if you're not japanese you suffer a
variety of forms of discrimination when
i lived there i often heard
unpleasant comments directed at me in
particular if i was with my wife who
looks asian
because her father is chinese
but that's a small number of people say
in japan the majority of people treat
you very well so again one shouldn't be
blowing these things out of proportion
not to mention the fact that having
lived in japan they love to get into
other cultures and good for them
how many japanese do i meet who are into
flamenco dancing or
i don't know uh
some aspect of
thai
burmese culture or
uh they go to france and
and uh you know work in a restaurant for
five ten years and learn their way up
and then come home and start a french
restaurant where they produce french
food and it's it's just as good as as
what you might get in france but it has
a bit of a japanese influence and all of
this is good stuff
culture belongs to the world to all of
us and shouldn't be used to uh you know
beat the tomtom of uh sort of uh
identity politics so a bit of a rant and
i look forward i'm sure i'll get some
pushback and just to prove that uh
cultural appropriation is a good thing
something that i indulge in because i
think
all the cultures of the world belong to
all of us
there's no reason why a korean person
can't sing italian opera
why a person from
brazil africa russia can't do i don't
know indian music it's all out there for
us to enjoy and participate in and and
it's that kind of feeling about
discovering the cultures of the world
that um you know it used
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
and i will finish off by singing a
japanese song if i can remember the
words
[Music]
[Music]
i can't remember but the principle is
the same in fact i think i'll tack on a
video of that song and let us all enjoy
everybody's culture
and that's all i have to say bye for now
hi there back
just briefly you know i was going to
attack on this video of uh
a person singing shireto koryojo and
it's a wonderful video that i found on
youtube because it actually takes you
through the kanji and explains the words
and it's a lovely song if the song was
apparently first put out in 1970 so i
want to encourage you i can't apparently
i can't tack it onto my video for
copyright reasons but i've put a link up
in the description box and i really
encourage you to click on it to hear
this lovely song especially if you are
learning japanese bye for now
[Music]
you